end of my third year of medical school
i'm going to the gym one day
riding my bike as i always do i get i
get to the gym i get off my bike go to
lock it up and i was like
my back really hurts like really hurt
not like oh it's a little stiff like
something feels
horrible so i started walking
down the steps to the gym and i was like
not gonna happen today like i mean i
couldn't i couldn't
do anything i couldn't tie my shoe so i
just went back got on my bike
road rode back to my apartment told my
roommate i was like hey man i'm gonna go
lay it lay down upstairs
the next morning i woke up i couldn't
get out of bed and to make a
very long story short over the next two
weeks i completely deteriorated
um you know i was at the point where i
could
get in and go to the hospital but i had
to like have the nurses this is back in
the wild west days where you could just
sort of get anything you needed at the
pharmacy
you know i'd get nurses or residents to
inject tort all into me
which is a really strong end said i
could only
sleep if i laid in an l shape over
the nurses station and it just wasn't
getting any better and then one day
it the pain changed immediately i
realized in retrospect what happened
a herniated disc had fragment had broken
off so the pain in my back dissipated
but now
i had this what turned out to be a four
centimeter fragment sitting on my s1
nerve root
so now it felt like my left foot was
being skinned
from the body but that was constant so
that was an unrelenting pain
and it could only be sort of brought
under control if i could put my foot
into a bag of ice because then i could
make my foot go numb
and then i could take some pain medicine
so this went on for another week and
then the dean of the medical school saw
me limping through the hospital he said
what's wrong and
i told him and he dragged me down to the
er we got a mri that showed all of this
and i was in surgery the next morning
this was a sunday night monday morning
i'm in the or
it turned into a disaster the guy who
operated on me operated on the wrong
side
so i woke up the left issue was still
present but now i had what's called a
foot drop on the right side
so foot drop is when the nerve
that holds your foot up which we take
for granted when we walk
but if you don't have the ability to
what's called dorsiflex
um your foot would drop you can't walk
you'll end up dragging your
toe and you keep tripping this story
i mean we could spend three hours on the
story because it's so idiotic
the punch line is i eventually needed
many trips back to the operating room
this guy refused to believe there's
anything wrong with me it took another
amazing doctor and neurologist to
actually intervene on my behalf
and three months later i'm
unable to walk i'm unable to do anything
my mom actually had to fly down from
toronto to look after me
um and i'm sort of
you know you go through the the
checklist right so so there's
i don't know if you've ever heard of
elizabeth kubler-ross
i don't think she's alive anymore but
she wrote a very
famous book on the stages of
dying and it goes through like anger and
denial and finally acceptance at the end
right
and so you know bargaining like it's
something that would make sense if you
and i'm sure you've i've heard of that
before yeah and you've probably watched
it on
really small scales yeah you know like
in combat you might see these things
over the course of compressed and yeah
dealt with it yeah with a cancer patient
you might see this stretched out over a
year
and so i was kind of going through this
on my own right where initially it was
like
oh my god what if i don't finish this
rotation i'm doing right now what's
called a surgical sub internship
to oh well what if i don't graduate on
time to
what if i can't be a surgeon and then it
was what if i don't walk ever again
um so somewhere along the way
i don't remember exactly when probably
like a month and a half into this
i finally caved in and started taking
pain medicine i
i thought that's where the story was
going i was like at some point
he's gonna get on the opiates yep and i
had been
so reluctant to do so initially been so
stoic you know just taking my nsaids
and even using benadryl which is a
horrible pain medication
of course but it sedates you through
some of the pain
and so i you know i started taking
percocet
and percocet is um it's typically 10
milligrams of oxycodone so oxycodone is
the fast acting
version and it's stronger than say a
vike so a vicodin is tylenol and
hydrocodone
immediate acting but hydrocodone is not
as strong as oxycodone so percocet is
stronger than vicodin
they both have tylenol it's just the
opiate is stronger
and so you know if you take a percocet
which would have 500 milligrams of
tylenol and 10 milligrams of oxycodone
you know i probably was taking you know
you start taking two three four five six
of those a day you develop a tolerance
and eventually
you there's a longer acting version
called oxycontin which is just a time
released version of oxycodone
so then you would take that twice a day
so at my peak i was probably taking
80 milligrams of oxycontin a day plus
another 120 milligrams of oxycodone
i just got rid of the tylenol all
together you can just get straight
oxycodone
and so i'm about 200 milligrams a day of
equivalent and again if you know if i
took that today i would just die
you just stop breathing but at the time
you know you build up this tolerance
but it also there was this point where i
realized
that i wasn't just taking it for the
physical pain
right and i think this is the single
most important insight i had
that when coupled with reading that book
six months later was the
i think the single most important
realization i ever had with respect to
to this problem which was at some point
it was i was just so depressed that i
couldn't walk
and i was so worried that you know i'd
never be able to do anything again
that at least the drug gave me a high
that took me away from that
and so then it got to the point where i
was just taking that drug all the time
and i just stopped engaging like wasn't
engaged with anyone anything
and then i sort of had this realization
that that was happening and i was like
i i want to stop so at the time i was
dating
this girl she was an anesthesiology
resident she was a few years older than
me
just the coolest coolest person and i
said to her she was kind of the only one
that knew what was going on
because at the time even the doctors who
were prescribing this like
this just wasn't on people's radar as a
problem back then i think today people
would be like
homeboy's got 200 milligrams of
oxycontin a day that's probably not good
but at the time it was just like
it was like tic tacs right so that would
legitimately kill like if i took 200
milligrams would that that would
really jack someone up i would think i
think if i took 200 today i would stop
breathing yeah because that's how
opiates kill you they repress they
inhibit respiratory drive
that's what whenever whenever someone
overdoses on heroin they just stop
breathing
um so yeah i think 200 would
i don't know we'd have to i'd have to
look at the farmer we don't have to
actually
take your word on this one um so the
girl you're dating
she she said you can't just stop right
you the withdrawal is so painful that
you have to taper off
you have to probably go on methadone and
then you'd have to start some pretty
potent antidepressants
like maois or tcas you have to go on a
drug like nortriptyline which is in and
of itself kind of a crazy thing
and i was like yeah but i think i'm just
gonna stop cold turkey
now unlike alcohol so if you took an
alcoholic
you know you took someone who's drinking
20 alcohol
you know alcoholic beverages a day and
they've been doing that forever
and you stop them they will die they
will get something called delirium
tremens and they will die
a horrible cardiac death they will break
into arrhythmias and they will die so
when we had alcoholics in the hospital
let's say we had to operate on somebody
who happened to be an alcoholic
we would actually just put them on an
ethanol iv we weren't even trying to
detox them
we just want to make sure they didn't
die and go into these delirium tremens
but but heroin and opiate is not like
that it is not
physiologically lethal to stop cold
turkey
it's just unbearable and so i was like
i'm going to do it so against her
better judgment i just stopped one day
and she could not have been more right
it was the darkest i mean i can laugh
about it now
it was the darkest month of my life it
was a month oh at least
i mean it was i would just sit on a park
bench
for the whole afternoon like complete
flat affect
but it's all mental it's not a physical
thing no there's physical stuff going on
i mean
but but no it's it's yeah you know you
you sort of
like you know opiates make you itch like
crazy you get constipated so there's
like a reversal of a whole bunch of
physical stuff but the biggest thing is
the craving and the depression
um and so the depression of coming off
this thing was
brutal um in many ways and i don't tell
that story to say
well look at how special i am that i
detox that's not the point at all
i had two things going for me that
virtually no junkie has going for them
right the first is
i didn't have a network of people around
me that were doing the same thing
so i was sort of the only guy doing it
so for me to go and be around my friends
was to be around people who weren't
doing this
we always used to joke that if you
really want to kick a heroin habit you
have to get a whole bunch of new friends
like you you don't get to decide you're
not doing heroin and then go back and
hang with your friends that are doing
hair when you need to watch train
spotting to learn that
the second thing and perhaps the more
important thing is i finally did connect
with a doctor who was able to put me on
the right path so i i had ended up going
back to the operating room
probably half a dozen times over the
course of the year to have
all these problems corrected and then i
found something else to fixate on which
was physical therapy so i started to
you know even though it didn't seem like
exercise it wouldn't seem like exercise
today at the time it was the first
activity i was able to do
and so you know within six months i
could like walk
like a reasonable distance again and so
i would be spending three hours a day at
physical therapy just doing like the
most trivial exercises
but basically the root cause of my
depression was getting better
so that's really the only reason i think
i was able to kind of detox off this
stuff
whereas i think for many people a it's
not clear what the root cause is or b
it's not getting better if it is clear
and so that's why i think it's really
it's a it's a brutal addiction
and it seems like also you're you had a
future
right you had a life you were in medical
school you're going to you know you're
going to
do something whereas a lot of these
people that are drug addicts
what are they they have no life that
they're looking forward to they're just
looking forward to it absolutely
and so in february of that senior year
when i had to submit
my rank list i think we match in march i
misspoke earlier
i was still not functional perfectly
like there was
no way in february of 2001 that i could
have withstood a surgical residency
but i had to make a decision at that
point which was will i be ready on july
1st
and if i won't be i should not submit my
rank i should defer a year
sit out a year in medical school
whatever and i remember that was the
hardest decision i'd make and i just
gambled i was like you know what i'm
going to be ready and i'm going to make
it happen no matter what and so i
submitted
matched and then in addition to now
reading the corner to prepare for
baltimore
and reflecting on my own sort of
struggle with addiction which was
completely fresh in my mind
i'm also like rehabbing like it's my day
job
and going through like is and i most
people take the last quarter of med
school off but i didn't have the ability
to do that now because i did
i had to go straight through till
graduation day because i'd missed so
much time during my injury